>> Pete: WELCOME TO JIMENTD I'M
PETE HEGSETH IN ON THIS SUMMER
FRIDAY NIGHT.
I KNOW WHAT YOU ARE THINKING
LAST NIGHT WE WITNESSED ONE OF
THE MOST DISTURBING SCENES IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, JOE BIDEN, STANDING
BEFORE A DICTATORIAL-LIKE
BACKGROUND WITH TROOPS STANDING
AT THE READY SCREAMING WITH HIS
FISTS IN THE AIR.
AND HE CALLED HALF THE COUNTRY A
THREAT TO OUR REPUBLIC.
>> WE MUST BE HONEST WITH EACH
OTHER AND WITH OURSELVES.
TOO MUCH OF WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
OUR COUNTRY TODAY IS NOT NORMAL.
DONALD TRUMP AND THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS REPRESENT AN
EXTREMISM THAT THREATENS THE
VERY FOUNDATIONS OF OUR
REPUBLIC.
>> Pete: UNCLE JOE THE GUY WHO
CAMPAIGNED ON SAVING THE SOUL OF
AMERICA TO HIM THIS IS EXTREMISM
AT ITS PEAK.
♪ YMCA
♪ IT'S FUN TO STAY AT THE YMCA
>> Pete: REMEMBER THAT?
IF YOU WAIVED AN AMERICAN FLAG,
CHANTED LET'S GO BRANDON, OTHER
EVEN DANCED TO YMCA YOU ARE AN
STREAMIST.
YOU ARE A FASCIST AND YOU LIVE A
LIFE OF DARKNESS AND CHAOS.
>> NATION OF FEAR, DIVISION AND
A DARKNESS.
MAGA REPUBLICANS HAVE MADE THEIR
CHOICE.
THEY EMBRACE ANGER.
THEY THRIVE ON CHAOS THEY LIVE
NOT IN THE LIGHT OF TRUTH BUT IN
THE SHADOW OF LIES.
BUT TOGETHER, TOGETHER WE CAN
CHOOSE A DIFFERENT PATH.
WE CAN CHOOSE A BETTER PATH
FORWARD TO THE FUTURE.
A FUTURE OF POSSIBILITY, A
FUTURE TO BUILD AND DREAM AND
HOPE.
>> Pete: I DON'T REMEMBER MAGA
RALLIES BEING SO DARK.
WE JUST SHOWED YOU A CLIP OF ONE
RIGHT THERE.
SORRY, WRONG SIDE.
PRETTY GOOD TIME.
I HAVE BEEN TO MANY.
THEY ARE A GOOD TIME.
A CELEBRATION OF AMERICA.
MAYBE JOE BIDEN WOULD HAVE BEEN
A LITTLE MORE CONVINCING IF HE
WASN'T STANDING IN FRONT OF A
CREEPY BLOOD RED BACK DROP OUT
OF SOVIET RUSSIA.
YOU MUST HAVE IMAGINED HOW HE
FELT AFTER STARGS AT IT FOR 20
MINUTES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M ON NO SLEEP.
NO SLEEP.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE IN
THERE ALL NIGHT LONG THINGS ARE
CREAKING AND CRACKING AND THAT
RED LIGHT IS BURNING MY BRAIN.
>> YOU LOOK A LITTLE STRESSED.
>> OH, I'M STRESSED.
>> BUT JOE BIDEN DID DELIVER
SOME NEWS LAST NIGHT, WE LEARNED
FROM HIM THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
NOW THE PARTY OF LAWLESSNESS.
I KNOW WHAT YOU ARE THINKING.
HEAR IT FROM YOURSELF.
>> MAGA REPUBLICANS DO NOT
RESPECT THE CONSTITUTION.
THEY DO NOT BELIEVE IN THE RULE
OF LAW.
THEY DO NOT RECOGNIZE THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE.
>> Pete: ORWELLIAN BACK DROP MAY
BE GIVING ME SOME AMNESIA BUT
I'M PRETTY SURE HE HAS BEEN ON
THE SIDE OF DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
LETTING CRIMINALS OUT THROUGH
BAIL REFORM.
OPEN BORDERS.
RIGHT?
I GUESS FACTS DON'T REALLY
MATTER WHEN DEMOCRACY IS ON THE
LINE.
THAT'S WHY BIDEN IS CALLING HIS
SUPPORTERS TO GET TOUGH AND
STAND UP FOR DEMOCRACY.
[POUNDING]
>> BLOOD ALONE MOVES THE WHEELS
OF HISTORY!
IT HAS BEEN A LIFETIME STRUGGLE.
POUNDING]
A NEVER ENDING FIGHT.
IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO FIGHT!
WE ARE WARRIORS!
>> Pete: COME ON, PRODUCERS,
THAT WAS, OF COURSE, THE WRONG
CLIP.
BUT IT'S NOT TOO FAR OFF FROM
THE REAL ONE.
>> A LONG TIME WE TOLD OURSELVES
THAT AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IS
GUARANTEED.
BUT IT'S NOT.
WE HAVE TO DEFEND IT.
PROTECT IT.
STAND UP FOR IT EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF US.
>> Pete: INSURRECTION KIND OF
SOUNDS LIKE HE IS CALLING FOR
INSURRECTION.
IS HE OBVIOUSLY NOT HOLDING IT
BACK.
IF YOU ARE NOT ON HIS SIDE,
YOU'RE THE PROBLEM.
YOU DESERVE THE WORST.
YOU ARE THE ENEMY.
AND IF YOU DON'T THINK HE IS
TALKING ABOUT YOU, YOU WOULD BE
WRONG.
HIS PRESS SECRETARY KARINE
JEAN-PIERRE JUST YESTERDAY SAID
IF YOU ARE NOT ON THEIR SIDE,
YOU KNOW, THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY, THEIR FAVORITE
DYSTOPIAN PHRASE YOU ARE
EXSTRATEGIC IF WE ARE SO BAD WHY
DID SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER JUST
SPEND OVER $3 MILLION ON THE
MAGA MOVEMENT TODAY?
HIS SUPER PACS HAVE BEEN PUMPING
MONEY TO HELP AMERICA FIRST
CANDIDATES WIN THEIR PRIMARIES.
SOUNDS LIKE DEMOCRATS LOVE
SPENDING MONEY ON PEOPLE THEY
CALL FASCISTS.
I'M SORRY, THE FACT CHECKERS AT
CNN WOULD LIKE TO CORRECT THE
RECORD.
>> TALKED ABOUT A MAGA
PHILOSOPHY, A SEMI FASCISM OF
MAGA PHILOSOPHY.
HE DIDN'T SAY REPUBLICANS WERE
FASCIST.
>> MAGGIE HAS NOT EVEN SAID.
>> DID HE NOT CALL THEM
FASCISTS.
HE CALLED THE MAGA PHILOSOPHY TO
SEMI FASCISM.
HE DID NOT CALL ALL REPUBLICANS
FASCIST.
THAT'S NOT TRUE I'M SORRY IT'S
NOT TRUE.
>> Pete: IT'S NOT TRUE THANK
YOU, DON.
WE WILL CORRECT THE RECORD YOU
ARE JUST A SEMI FASCIST IF YOU
VOTED THAT WAY.
KIND OF LIKE BEING A
SEMIPREGNANT BIRTHING PERSON.
DON'T WORRY, ACCORDING TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, NONE OF THIS AT ALL
IS POLITICAL.
IT'S REALLY ALL FOR DEMOCRACY.
>> IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THE
CRITICISMS AND QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHY THE PRESIDENT DELIVERED WHAT
SOUNDED VERY MUCH LIKE A
POLITICALLY CHARGED SPEECH AS AN
OFFICIAL WHITE HOUSE EVENT
TAXPAYER FUNDED WITH TWO MARINES
IN UNIFORM.
>> STANDING UP FOR DEMOCRACY IS
NOT POLITICAL.
>> Pete: I HAVE TO SAY IT AGAIN.
WE ARE NOT A DEMOCRACY.
WE ARE A REPUBLIC.
A CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC BUT,
YOU KNOW, DETAILS.
DEMOCRACY IS THE CATCH WORD THEY
USE FOR EVERYTHING THEY WANT TO
GET DONE.
WELL, AT LEAST KJP REMEMBERED
LAST NIGHT'S SPEECH.
THE PRESIDENT, ON THE OTHER
HAND, SEEMS TO HAVE FORGOTTEN
EVERYTHING HE READ OFF OF HIS
TELEPROMPTER.
HERE IS HIM TODAY.
>> DO YOU CONSIDER ALL TRUMP
SUPPORTERS TO BE A THREAT TO THE
COUNTRY?
>> KEEP TRYING TO MAKE THAT
CASE.
I DON'T CONSIDER ANY TRUMP
SUPPORTER TO BE A THREAT TO THE
COUNTRY.
>>
>> Pete: I DON'T CONSIDER ANY
TRUMP SUPPORTERS I JUST TALKED
ABOUT MAGA REPUBLICANS BUT I
DON'T THINK ANY TRUMP SUPPORTERS
ARE A THREAT.
IT'S ASTONISHING.
BUT, CAN WE REALLY BLAME JOE
BIDEN FOR NOT REMEMBERING?
THE HIGHLIGHT OF HIS NIGHT
WASN'T BEING A DEFENDER OF
DEMOCRACY IT WAS GETTING A KISS
FROM THE MISSES DEMOCRACY, THANK
YOU.
[CHEERS]
♪
>> Pete: WHICH WAY DO I TURN?
IS THIS MIC ON.
WAS THAT KISS GOOD?
EVERYBODY?
WE DON'T THINK JOE BIDEN HAD A
CHANGE OF HEART.
WHAT JOE BIDEN SAID LAST NIGHT
IS EXACTLY WHAT THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY THINKS OF US.
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR MICHAEL
HAYDEN YOU KNOW THIS SAID
DEMOCRATS -- SAID EXACTLY WHAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE ALWAYS THOUGHT OF
GOD-FEARING AMERICANS, TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, THAT THEY ARE MORE
DANGEROUS THAN A TERRORIST
GROUP.
WORSE THAN AL-QAEDA AND ISIS.
YOU NAME IT.
WHY?
WELL, BECAUSE WE LOVE THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU ARE NOW A FASCIST IF YOU
WANT FREE SPEECH.
YOU ARE A THREAT IF YOU WANT A
SAY IN WHAT IS TAUGHT IN YOUR
KID'S CLASSROOM.
IMAGINE THAT.
OR IF YOU BELIEVE IN YOUR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO DEFEND
YOURSELF AND YOUR FAMILY.
YOU ARE AN EXTREMIST IF YOU TAKE
A STAND AGAINST FAUCI'S
AUTHORITARIAN MASK MANDATE AND
YOU ARE CERTAINLY A RACIST IF
YOU DON'T WANT AN OPEN BORDER.
TALK ABOUT CHAOS OR CRIMINALS
RUNNING THE STREETS.
WE COULD KEEP GOING ON AND ON
ALL PROGRAM.
YOU SEE, THEY CALL US, ALL OF
THESE THINGS BECAUSE WE DON'T
AGREE WITH THEM.
THEY HAVE TURNED THE PATRIOTIC
OPPOSITION INTO TREASONOUS
OUTLAWS.
EVEN IF THEY TRY TO DENY IT THE
NEXT DAY BECAUSE WE STAND FOR
FREEDOM AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WE KNOW LAST NIGHT'S SPEECH WAS
JUST DEFLECTION.
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS AND JOE BIDEN
WHO SEEK TO RUN